جمله عالم طيور ماكرون
[موسيقى]
بايجاز من اسطنبول مرحبا بكم تركيا تدخل
مرحله الصمت الانتخابي عشيه الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي
يتنافس فيها الرئيس اردوغان ومرشح تحالف
المعارضه كمالك
وخلال هذه الفتره يحضر نشر اي اخبار او
تعليقات تتضمن دعايه الانتخابيه كما يمنع
تداول كل ما من شانه ان يؤثر على الحريه
التامه للناخبين وقبل ساعات على فتح
صناديق الاقتراع الرئيس اردوغان يدعو
الشعب التركي للتوجه بشكل كثيف للتصويت
لاثبات مسماه بالعرس الديمقراطي وقال انه
سيحرز نصرا كبيرا ولن يكون هناك اي خاسر
في تركيا سواء من يستصغر الناخبين لانهم
لم يصوتوا لهم
بالمقابل انتقد مرشح تحالف الشعب كمالك
اوغلو ما سماه الاداء الاقتصادي الضعيف
للحكومه الذي اذى العائلات ومنعها من
تقديم الغذاء الصحي لاطفالها كما وعد
بانشاء مراكز الاطفال وبمنح العائلات
المحتاجه مبلغا شهريا وبعدم قطع خدمات
الماء والكهرباء او الغاز عنها
المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات يعلن ان اعداد
مصوتي الخارج في البعثات الدبلوماسيه
والمعابر والمطارات ارتفع الى اكثر من
مليون و920 الفا على ان يتم اغلاق صناديق
الاقتراع في المطارات والمعابر الحدوديه
في تمام الساعه الخامسه من مساء يوم الاحد
وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شاوش اوغلو
يقولوا ان بلاده مصممه على اعاده السوريين
دون خطاب عنصري وان الجزء الاكبر منهم
يرغب في العوده الى بلاده كما اوضح ان
اكثر من نصف مليون شخص عادوا الى المناطق
الامنه في شمال سوريا الى اللقاء